-We were talking backstage.
-Yeah.
-The last time you were here,
was right before
your show started.
-That's right.
Yes, two years ago.
-Two years ago.
And the other guest that night
was an up-and-coming politician
named Hillary Clinton.
-Yes.
-And had you met her before?
-That was the first time
I ever met her.
And my friend Allana totally
rushed her in her dressing room
and made us
take a picture together.
And it's so blurry,
'cause we're all too excited.
-That's great.
I think that's nice.
To have a photo so blurry
to show the moment is great.
-Exactly. Yeah.
-Compared to what
you thought it would be like
and what it's been like,
how has your show affected you
over these last two years?
-Well, as a citizen, I would say
it's a similar experience,
where I thought
it was gonna be one way,
and it became another way.
-Yeah.
-But it's been a very wild ride.
It's been really fun,
it's been invigorating
and terrifying,
and a lot of different things.
-Well that's good.
I certainly enjoy watching it.
Another show
I really enjoy watching --
You actually share a studio
with "Last Week Tonight,"
with John Oliver.
-I do, yes, we share a space.
-And you guys have obviously
known each other
for a long time.
-Yeah, we have.
-You used to work together.
Sharing the same physical space,
do you ever leave notes
for one another?
-We never really
cross paths that much.
But I did actually --
I did engrave my --
I did engrave something
in his desk.
And I don't know
if he knows that.
[ Laughter ]
I took, like --
I don't know.
I guess I was randomly
holding a knife.
And I think, under his desk --
As one does.
Under his desk somewhere, it
says, like, "Sam Bee was here."
-Oh, that's great.
-Yeah.
-What a fun thing
to find one day.
-I know.
-And then probably
work backwards
to the same question of,
"Why does Sam have a knife?"
-It's been years.
[ Laughter ]
I know.
-Your show, obviously,
very hard on the president,
to a point
that some people believe
there is
something shady going on.
There's a bit
of a conspiracy theory
out there about your show.
-Yes, my dad has a lot
of friends, who think that --
They have conspiracy theories
about me.
They think that every time
I mention Hillary Clinton
I get $25.
[ Laughter ]
Which I do,
because we're best friends,
but I'm sure you get that, too.
I mean, everybody thinks
that when you make jokes
in the typical comedy sphere,
that, like,
George Soros
provides you with...
Yeah, it's so funny to me
that no one thinks
you can just come to these
conclusions independently...
-Yeah, no, no, no, no.
-...without cash reward.
-It's for a $25 per diem.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Just cruising along
with all that
sweet, sweet George Soros cash.
-And last Friday --
So, you guys are off
for a little bit.
-We were.
-'Cause obviously Friday --
We had to wait till today.
You guys
are gonna approach it
in two days, on Wednesday.
-I know.
You have to do it every day.
I'm so sorry.
-No, but I --
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, like, no, it's good.
-I think
there are great difficulties
to doing it once a week,
as well.
-Yes, there are.
I mean, you get to cover --
You get to do it every day.
-Well, I think it's --
So much is --
I'm trying to find
the right word for it.
So much is [bleep] out
every day that...
[ Laughter ]
...doing the show every day,
you're just like --
We're just running around
with a bucket.
-Sure, totally.
-Like, you're an actual plumber
who like might actually
fix the toilet.
-We get the fire hose in the
face of feces, as well.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But we get to sit back
and kind of analyze for,
you know,
a couple of days at least.
But, you know, there's a lot of
man things to talk about.
-Yeah.
You, uh...
[ Laughter ]
-Not you.
-No, no, I know.
But there are --
Being on Team Man,
it's been a --
I feel like we're not a --
not a great week.
We need to fire our coach
and hire a new GM or something.
-I know, you do.
[ Laughter ]
-But on Friday, obviously,
the plea deal happens.
-Uh-huh.
-And what is the reaction
in the "Full Frontal" offices?
-Uh, well...
Okay, there's a moment --
I guess,
when it comes to the plea deal,
it really is sad
what passes for joy.
-Yeah.
-Because you feel that --
where you're like,
"Oh, it's so exciting!"
And then you're like,
"Every smile is joyless.
Every piece of laughter
is mirthless."
Like, I remember I woke up
Friday morning,
and I listen to the
New York Times podcast,
and they were really
intensely talking about
how the tax bill was like
a trillion dollars off.
And I LOL'd.
I was like, "Ha ha ha!
A trillion dollars?!
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh, my God."
[ Laughter ]
And then --
And then, it passed.
It's really a trillion and a
half, don't worry.
-We listen to the same podcast.
I don't know
if you found this recently.
-The music
is very triggering now.
-The music is triggering.
It's "The Daily."
It's fantastic.
Sometimes the news is so bad
that I just speed it up.
Like, I try to listen to it
just talking very fast, like,
"And now it looks like
Republicans will pass the bill,
and it's gonna be $1.5 trillion.
It's gonna hurt
the middle class."
I'm like, "Oh, just get it out!
Just get it out!"
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to spend
a lot of time with this.